what did you learn making
peacemaker that perhaps you weren't
expecting going in
well i'm not sure if i was totally not
expecting it but i
love television storytelling you are
able to let things
relax you are able to really fully focus
on the characters
something can be funny it can go on for
a little while you get into the nuances
of the dramatic relationships
that you don't have time for in a movie
and you don't have to have that
constantly
chugging along thing that you have in a
movie so i loved the format of
television
i had a blast and i think it suited me
very well
yeah that's that's thing that i think
people don't realize is in a movie the
train has to keep running
and then on a series you can have these
quiet moments that just play out for
five or ten minutes
and you don't you know and you can just
talk yeah you can
you can go out you can have a scene that
doesn't have to do with anything
in the tv show because it's such a large
format you know we've got eight hours of
storytelling
that we can have something go off and it
doesn't really need to
you know go to point a and point b and
point c like you do in a movie
is the series one big storyline or a lot
of little things with maybe
a bigger arc at the end it's one big
storyline i mean
every character has their own story so
there's the
six main characters of peacemaker uh
leo to adebayo who's danielle brooks
amelia harcourt is jennifer holland
um uh vigilante who's freddie stroma
um uh clemson myrn who is uh chuck
williams
and john economos uh who is uh steve
agee
and those six characters it's really an
ensemble about
those six characters where are you in
the editing process
pretty far along the first three are
pretty much completely edited
uh four and five are coming along
they're a little slower because they
were directed by other people
six i just saw the first cut of last
night which i directed i'm really happy
with
and then eight is most of the way edited
and set so it's seven
which is brand are the episodes like
40 something minutes are they more like
50 something minutes
no they're more like 40 something
minutes or more they vary
some are longer than others and some are
shorter but uh
but basically i was kind of in the range
of what is your traditional hour-long
actual traditional hour long which is
you know you know between 40 and 44
minutes
i know that you loved making the series
i know i've seen it on your instagram
um do you see yourself because this is
your big first
big series like this do you see yourself
doing more
television in the future after guardians
or do you see yourself
mixing both like television and movies
um i i see myself doing more television
for sure
mostly because of peacemaker and then
one other thing we're talking about
but uh but i uh i i don't know what it's
gonna be i'm gonna
try to go i i did something i don't love
doing which is stacking up projects
so i had you know suicide squad
peacemaker
christmas special guardians 3 for a long
time and i don't like doing that i like
doing something like i did with suicide
squad figuring out i want to do it and
then going straight into it figuring out
peacemaker going straight into it
i don't like having things that i'm
doing that i decided to do three years
ago